tonsai one started little bit about some
movies you got coming up you've got
Cinderella haven't you got pan as well
tell me a little bit first of all about
Cinderella who you worked with on that
working with the director Kenneth
Branagh hmm well Cinderella I worked on
just before Christmas um it stars Cate
Blanchett Helena Bonham Carter Richard
Madden of Game of Thrones and Lily James
plays Cinderella and Kenneth Branagh I
had worked with before on Jack Ryan and
also in first my waterloo moes on a play
at the national theatre called Edmund um
years ago and he had we developed a
relationship since then and he was
waiting for the right part of him to
come up and a part of the captain who is
the princes adviser and best friend and
also combat trainer is a part that is is
a great I said it was it was great fun
to play it was almost like I really
think of a part that I can liken it to
because I don't think it's really been
it the character wasn't in the cartoon
so it was almost like made up for the
film but it was great to play he's the
guy that wants him to get the girl when
so many forces are acting against him to
get the guy so I think it's really
he's the moral center of the play of the
film you know so it was great fun I
think people are gonna really like you
it stays true to the kind of wholesome
love story that Cinderella is but it
brings a modern twist to the kind of
independent woman not just a woman that
is waiting to be you know you know
rescued but a woman that can do some
things and believe in herself her own
power ultimately it's her own belief in
herself that may set her free
I mean conventions which madan of course
thing the prince there and euros adviser
what was it like somebody's got this
game of Thrones background but you
didn't ever intersect your scene I
filmed in greater and he filmed a lot of
the stuff in Northern Ireland but we
connected straightaway when we got on
ser and I spent a lot of time together
all my scenes are with
and so we got to know each other quite
well and we've talked it's in
subsequently since he's great to work
with and really dedicated someone who
will do we had a sword fight where we
have a sparring session with a fencing
session in Cinderella and we had to
rehearse it over and over and over again
and you know I'm someone who likes to go
again and her something and every time I
would say let's do again he'd want to do
it two more times and that's that's good
because it pushes you to a point where
you get it right you know and I really
think we've got it right I've seen I've
seen about 12 minutes of it and it is
beautiful there's beautiful hopefully
people will really love them how much
kind of research and background work did
you have to do for because obviously you
do those fighting scenes I just I kind
of watched loads of Disney movies and
looked at the relationship between this
kind of relationship that exists in
those movies but also my kind of what I
did was develop my own character I drew
up his history throughout where he comes
from
and because it's her fantasy Kingdom me
ask you have to make up a fantasy place
it comes from but also I did a lot of
training with the drill sergeant on how
he walks and talks carries himself how
to handle a sword and because he is a
captain of the guard he is a man of
authority and commands the king's army
so you know he has to know how to do
that and so I did a lot of research on
soldiers and drill sergeants and all
that kind of thing so there lot that
kind of research forth
you